[Music]
you ready
i'm ready
nice knowing you spider-man excuse me
the entire world's about to forget that
peter parker is spider-man
uh everyone some people still know
that's not how the spell works so my
girlfriend's just gonna forget about
everything we've been through i mean is
she even gonna be my girlfriend all
right fine
everyone in the world is gonna forget
that you're spiderman except your
girlfriend thank you so much that
oh my god next okay let's not change the
parameters of this spell anymore while
i'm okay i'm done i'm done i swear i'm
done i'm done
now but my aunt may should really know
you just stop talking
ever since i got bit by that spider
i've only had one week
where my life has felt normal
that was when you found out
[Music]
when you botched that spell where you
wanted everyone to forget the peter
parker spiderman
we started getting some visitors
[Applause]
from every universe
hello
peter not peter parker
i'm sorry what was your name again dr
otto octavius
[Laughter]
wait no seriously what's your actual
name
are others out there we need to send
them back
so scooby-doo this crap you know all
this is kind of your mess i know a
couple of magic words myself starting
with the word please
please scooby-doo this crap
you're flying out into the darkness
to fight ghosts what do you mean
they all die fighting spider-man
it's their fate
i'm sorry kid
yeah me too don't
look there has to be another way there
isn't
they're a danger to our universe
you know how to take this away from me
peter
you're struggling
to have everything you want
while the world tries to make you choose
this is all my fault i can't save
everyone
[Applause]
what's happening
they're starting to come through
and i can't stop them
december 17th exclusively in movie
theaters tickets on sale november 29th
spider monday
[Music]